welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
above event episode 3 the streets of mos
espa streets that are filled with
lucasfilm's toy box of star wars easter
eggs so as always i'm going to break
down this episode shot by shot for all
the interesting filmmaking details
throughout the episode that you might
have overlooked the episode opens
outside of the palace as a bt-16 spider
droid crawls past we actually saw one of
these at the palace gate and returned
the jedi it has a bowl dangling
underneath containing a sloshing brain
because these droids are used by the
bomar monks of tatooine who transfer
their brains to the droid as a higher
state of enlightenment detached from
earthly senses actually in star wars
expanded universe literature which is no
longer canon bib fortuna met his end
when he joins those monks and then gets
his brain sucked out and while these
shows animators are certainly capable of
animating the droid's movement to look
smoother it looks like they deliberately
rendered it with a lower frame rate to
better evoke the stop-motiony movement
that was used in the original trilogy
films and the way that kind of motion
would make our skin crawl notice how as
it moves the droid randomly snaps that
lower claw like out of my way i am a
monk but i will cut you 88 breaks down
the moss espo criminal network and here
you see the businesses that were under
the protection of
the name that should not be spoken you
can say jabba
under the protection of
jabba their hat yeah i like how the
droid awkwardly tilts its head matching
the mannerisms of voice actor matt barry
and then he goes on to say after the
sailboats disaster
there was a power vacuum
bed fortuna assumed jabber's mantle yeah
88 calls it the sail barge disaster
rebranding it from how we saw it luke
han leia chewie and lando's heroic
escape if yeah awesome to
a humiliating structural collapse from
bigfortune to certain points of view 88
explains mos esper was divided amongst
three families the trend oceans took the
city center
the aqualish the workers district here
and the claytonians the starport and
upper sprawl hey don't forget the top
taglia's staten island episode one
actually showed the transocean leader
dokstrassi presenting a wookie pelt and
the other trans oceans glared at them as
they returned to the city center last
episode the aqualish leader was garfula
quacks who also presented a tribute we
have not seen the leadership from the
clutunians yet trailer footage does show
a clatunion at boba's table though they
discuss the blow to bubba's reputation
from the nightwind assassin strike mayor
has no power
somebody else is behind that play
that
could be
you want me to ask around yeah if it
wasn't the huts behind the nightwind it
could have just been the pike syndicate
but it does seem like this show is still
setting this up as a mystery
orchestrated by some unseen boss of
bosses which is why i think it is at
least still worth considering options
like a crimson dawn operation headed up
by kira watermonger lortha peele is
played by amazing character actor steven
root just as pissed at those youth
stealing his water as when lumber stole
his stapler i believe you have my
stapler and here he says ever since lord
fortuna was
perished
the streets have turned to chaos yeah i
love the acting redirect by root there
clearly about to say lord fortuna was
assassinated but he catches himself not
wanting to call boba fett a usurper to
his face even though that is what he is
peel apparently gave with a catchphrase
that he clearly rehearsed i am insulted
on your behalf at the disrespect these
urchids are showing you and i am
insulted on your behalf yeah yeah i'm
insulted on your behalf yeah that will
convince him boba says i grew up
surrounded by water well
tatooine was once completely covered
with water it's fascinating actually and
what is this
gang no no let that man speak it is
fascinating like the tuscans mentioned
last episode in legends tatooine's
climate change was a result of a
planet-wide bombing by the rakatans but
the exact backstory remains a mystery in
current star wars canon interesting how
they keep bringing it up though we may
get the fuller story in a series peel
describes the gang they are half man
have machine they modify their bodies
with droid parts to make themselves even
more deadly yes peel's disgust is a bit
unfounded tons of folks in the star wars
universe have cybernetic implants
including the woman he is talking to
fenix shand who glares at him as he says
this but maybe he's referring to
unnecessary cybernetic enhancements
instead of cybernetics used as
prosthetics so they head into the
workers district of moscow you can see
all the aqualishes in the area and they
come across those youths whose look in
chrome-colored bikes seem inspired
directly by the mods and rockers of
london in the 1960s who rode similarly
colorful and souped-up bikes their
leader is drash played by sophie
thatcher you may have seen her in
yellowjackets another one has a
cybernetic eye which looks like the same
prop that was seen on that nemourian
officer and the trade federation
battleship and phantom menace boba
surprises them by offering them jobs you
better fight as good as you talk dank
yes dank part of the profanity dank
ferric which we actually hear later this
episode and it's come up repeatedly on
the mandalorian thanks eric thank you
thank ferrick yet peter lewis clearly
listening in on all this is outraged no
no no
they stole from me
and you're just going to let them all
and boba pisses him off further by
giving him only 500 credits instead of
his overcharged rate of 1300 leaving the
guy fuming
okay
set the building on fire you may have
also caught how boba tells drash to have
the rest of her gak follow him gak was a
behind the scenes term among star wars
crew members for random bits of tech
according to lucasfilm's phil sostak
then in this shot outside the palace you
see that wart species that we also saw
last episode returns here to catch a
scurrier just like it did in that one
establishing shot in return of the jedi
but this time it snatches both the
scurrier and this reptilian bat showing
why it waited to let that scurrier get
so close and also like the spider droid
you'll notice the warts movement and its
burp had that same kind of stop motiony
frame rate as the gag back in 1983.
boba's flashback doe returns him to
kamino as his clone father jango's ship
departs and leaves him behind we saw a
flash of this during his lizard quest
last episode and as before the departing
ship forms a teardrop shape on his face
but now young boba's face with a
thunderclap flashes into his older
reflection and as the light of django's
ship exhaust fades the light of two
tatooine suns crossfade into the frame
and now we see boba a full member of the
tuscan tribe riding up bantha with both
a gaffy stick and the tuscan rifle that
we saw him with the mandalorian chapter
9 into the town of moss eisley where
stormtrooper helmets are stuck on pikes
just as we saw in the mandalorian
chapter 5. this is the moment they put
those in place and you'll notice behind
the spikes a cameo by pelimoto amy
sedaris's mechanic from that episode and
from season two trailed by her two pit
droids so boba meets with the pike
leader who is played by phil lamar who
voiced bail organa and a number of other
characters on clone wars and rebels he
also voiced hermes on futurama marvin
and pulp fiction and that one on
credited cameo where he caught peter
parker on the train in spider-man 2. now
notice how the pike's leader's robes
bear this sigil that is not the crest
that we have normally associated with
the pikes it actually kind of looks like
a death star fracturing which would
correspond to that anti-imperial
propaganda of those stormtrooper helmets
that these pikes might be using to exert
their new dominant in these outer rim
regions the pike mentions his superiors
on obi daya that's the pike home world
that was shown in season six and in
season seven episodes of clone wars and
then he says the kentucky striders have
already collected protection money for
the same territory you lay claim to yes
the kington striders are their names
canton is the home world of the nicto
species but boba returns to the tuscan
camp and just like luke returning to
uncle owen aunt peru on the moisture
farm he discovers his family massacred
they totally got the anakin skywalker
treatment but the women and the children
slaughtered like animals some of their
bodies are strung up to their tentpoles
almost crucifixion style as if to send a
cruel deliberate message to boba fett
and on these smoldering ruins is that
kenton strider tag that we saw them mark
on the moisture farm but i gotta say we
are still left to wonder if that gang
did this raw retaliation for boba's
attack at the tashi station or if they
had a similar meeting with the pikes and
the pikes might have been the ones to
tell them to do this actually in that
flashback of them for episode one the
gang's leader's vest has an aurabis and
red at the bottom the name and k it
looks like we know from last episode
that another was named emmett now we see
the chieftains corpse and his gaffy
stick that boba later throws on the fire
but it was hard to see if there were the
corpses of that female warrior or the
kid on that pile now boba does throw a
few more gappy sticks on the fire none
of them looks like the one the female
warrior sparred against him with there
was that smaller stick that boba got
from the kid at the end of episode one
but in this episode that kid was holding
a different stick so i don't know i have
hope at least that the two tuscans he
was closest with are still alive out
there because it's the one thing they
can't take away from us
now if your new year's resolution
includes some self-improvement there's
no cooler way to level up in 2022 than
to become a lord or lady established
titles is the project based on a
historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english they let
people buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so they can call
themselves a lord or a lady and in
return establish titles commits to
planting a tree it's a really fun way to
help preserve the beautiful woodlands
and biodiversity of scotland while
raising funds to support global
conservation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
roots your title packs give you a
numbered plot of dedicated land on
private estate in ardele aberdeen shire
scotland and an official certificate
with a crest these are really the best
way to start the new year in style
become a lord or lady of scotland with
established titles they are running a
new year celebration sale using the code
new rockstars to get an additional 10
percent off just go to
establishtitles.comrockstars to get your
gifts now but this somber meditative
moment is rarely awakened by black or
santan grabbing boba out of the back to
tank gotta say super brave of boba to go
all eastern promises and still lunge at
bk's leg instead of what i would do run
the hell out of the room bk electrifies
his brass knuckles which are on top of
the metal that was already injected into
his knuckles from his gladiator days and
he wallops boba's face releasing an
impact blast insane that this hook
doesn't immediately kill boba i guess uh
the healing nutrients from that back to
bath left them with a bit more
protection or maybe just some plot armor
but i love this detail as we saw on the
train last episode when boba's
technological approaches fail as he
fumbles with his armor he instead
reaches for the gaffy stick and that
actually leaves a mark on that wookie
later on effectively digging into his
shoulder and then he pulls it out of his
shoulder and goes for the leg getting a
nasty roar out of the wookie tuscan
tools working more effectively than
supposedly more advanced tech there's
something about that tree baby bk bites
boba's arm and as he dangles him this
might have just been tomorrow doing
something with his foot but a close-up
does grossly show one of his toes bent
upward
drash's gang jumps in to help out and
then bk turns onto those gamoreans
yeah i love the sound design of this
brawl the gemorian squeals as we heard
in return of the jedi and bk bellows a
wookie howl evoking chewbacca's cries of
anguish so finnick has to pull the
trapdoor but bk grabs that ledge like
ralphie not ready to leave santa
so finnick pulls the dagger from a rifle
and priced his hand loose i love how
that dagger remains wedged in his hand
down in the pit he does not care their
dining table has some roasted nuna a
food that we've seen in star wars before
also some type of squid dish there's
also a big gourd a blue spatuka in the
middle of the table and then the hutt
twins appear at the gate they seem to
apologize for sending black or sand and
kill them i love how that male twin
after mopping himself with that rodent
just tosses it aside like a sweat rag
and they give him a rancor wrangled by
danny trejo long-time collaborator of
director robert rodriguez they float in
on an anti-gravity barge that you know
that litter looked over at like oh come
on the hutts claim that the mayor
promised this territory to another
syndicate and the hutts are now leaving
to avoid the turf war but it's just hard
to take them at their word i mean not to
look a gift rancor in the mouth but i am
betting these huts aren't being entirely
sincere with this offer and might have
carved out their own side deal with the
pikes or whatever crimson dawn body
oversees this like notice their
non-response here here is your prisoner
i offer him back if you renounce all
claims to jabba's legacy on tatooine
yeah in the same beat these two huts
both slightly refuse to renounce jabba's
claim but also suggests that tatooine is
worthless but we all know it isn't
worthless and then the female hut says
referring to those zanti brothers who
enslaved bk early on and used him as a
gladiator but to bk surprise bobo
releases him take it from my next bounty
hunter don't work for skugholes
it's not worth it yes skughole is a
crass term we heard the mandalorian as
well see sorghum
looks like there's no star port no
industrial centers no population density
real backwater skuggle and then down in
the pit the wrangler explains that the
rancor is actually depressed raincore
are emotionally complex creatures
it imprints on the first human it sees
they're quite peaceful unless threatened
i love how this scene builds on the
complexities of the rancor species which
return of the jedi gave us just a taste
of when the wrangler malakili wept after
luke killed his rancor batissa and then
the wrangler says it is said that the
witches of daphomir even rode them
through the forest and fence yes the
witches of dathomir originally comes
from star wars legends literature a
female cult on the planet dathomir
created in the memory of a rogue jedi
knight alia and this cult generation
after generation forged a bond with the
rancors of the mountains of the planet
now star wars canon in more recent years
has reframed the witches of dathomir as
sex as groups like the night sisters
from clone wars who were led by maul's
mother talzin who helped restore his
body but here using the term witches of
dathomir returns the group to its
original history context and sets up the
possibility that we could see them in
live action my hope is that this group
shows up in the acolyte which is
supposed to be said even before the
prequels boba says
i want to learn to ride this one i've
ridden beast 10 times its size this is a
callback to the star wars holiday
special in 1978 which was the debut of
the boba fett character in that animated
segment when he rode a massive reptilian
creature in that cartoon the forked
staff that he carried looks like the
same prodder now carried by danny trejo
and remember in bad batch omega who was
another jango clone rode the mancor
moochie so riding makeours is something
that runs in this family this rancor
adorably imprints on boba and then he
orders it to be fed a full ronto carcass
rontos are the huge pack animals one of
whom george lucas added to moz eisley in
the 1997 special edition of a new hope
back at the mayor's office the major
domo tries to send them off again and
then he just totally tries to duck out
on his speeder
i like how right aesthetic shouts that
nervous major domo swerves his speeder
and kicks up a bunch of dust to make it
harder for them to follow they blow past
this frassel protocol droid
yeah sounded like the droid screamed
curse you at them and this reminds me a
lot of that opening police chase of
goonies where poor rosalita is almost
hit we see a bunch of mouse droids
buzzing around and then a pit droid
ducks but nearby is that same r5d4 red
astromech with the busted motivator that
we saw with pelimoto in season 2
originally nearly bought by owen and
luke from the jawas and the new hope as
they pass that pitroid pops back up and
cheers at them the cyborgs use their
go-go gadget spike heels and wrist
torches and then one crashes through
this painting this is original ralph
mcquarrie art depicting jabba's throne
room from the original trilogy however
notice how luke skywalker has been
removed from this rendition this comes
right after we saw ralph mcquarrie art
inspiring the tuscan armory last episode
they zoom past a few bits carded by an
espsa droid just like the one that
carted anakin and padme when they
visited moss espa and attacked the
clones i love how it speeds up so that
its passengers get hit instead of him
drash crashes the major domo into a
fruit market where like biff and back to
the future
crap just spills all over him but in
this case it is the mail run fruit seen
throughout the animated series and now
in live action i think we also saw
maelrun on the menu in the cafe in the
mandalorian season two finale the major
demo tries to restart the engine
that sound effect of his dead speeder
engine is the same real-life plane
engine sound effect used in the original
trilogy when the falcon fails to start
an empire oh yeah watch this
also in the prequels when anakin's pod
racers stall
the major domo confesses that the mayor
is working with the pikes and then we
get a lucasfilm circle wipe to the
spaceport of mos espo which we learned
at the beginning of this episode was
controlled by the platoonians so that's
where things are headed next and then we
see another hask and some uh revealing
outerwear passing the starliner where
several pikes have arrived and boba and
fennec prepare to go to war that's
everything i spotted this episode you
can support new rock stars by checking
out our merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ee evos follow
me rockstars subscribe to the rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thank you for watching boba
[Music]
you